hi klicksum high Gentleman du hast dich
Z schon mehrfach gegen Homophobie
ausgesprochen hast aber trotzdem Song
mit sisler aufgenommen der mehrfach in
seinen Texten zum Mord und Schwulen
aufruft außerdem hast du in deinem me
Profil die homophoben Künstler SIS und
caplon unter deinen Topfs wie passt es
für dich zusammen und warum sprichst du
dich auch gegen Auftrittsverbote für
diese homophoben Künstler das ist eine
ganz komplexe Frage und dazu muss ich
auch eine ganz etwas längere Antwort
geben ja weil ich bin jemand der
zwischen zwei Kulturen oft hin und her
tingelt ja und wir sind verschieden und
wir haben verschiedene Ansichten und
trotzdem haben wir auch
Gemeinsamkeiten im regy wird eine
Symbolsprache oft benutzt ja da werden
Metaphern verwendet dieses fireburn ist
eine Metapher dafür dass man etwas dass
man gegen etwas ist so homophobie ist
nicht was was nur im reggy stattfindet
sondern die Bibel ist voller Homophobie
der Papst sagt genau dasselbe was ein
sisla sagt nur vielleicht nicht ganz so
radikal
und ich persönlich distanziere mich
davon ich habe auch immer wieder
Diskussion in Jamaica und sag hey ich
kann nicht verstehen wie jemand ein
anderen Menschen aufgrund seiner
Sexualität diskriminiert so und trotzdem
kann ich akzeptieren wenn jemand sagt
ich kann Homosexualität mit meinem
Glauben nicht
vereinbaren es ist auch erwiesen dass
irgendwie in in Russland z.B viel mehr
Übergriffe stattfinden als in Jamaica
obwohl es in Russland jetzt keine regy
Musik gibt so ja ich meine jeder
Übergriff ist zu viel ganz klar ähm aber
die Diskussion ist im Moment so ein
bisschen aus dem Ruder gelaufen ja wenn
Aktivisten buttersäureanschläge verüben
auf Konzertbesucher friedvolle wenn regy
Künstler Auftrittsverbote kriegen obwohl
sie keine homophoben Texte singen und
das auch vorher unterschreiben ja ähm
wenn
die auf die gleiche Stufe gestellt
werden wie talibankämpfer wenn reggy
Platten auf dem Index landen neben
rechtsradikalen Platten da da stimmt
einfach irgendwas nicht und ich ich bin
jemand der auch eine andere Meinung
akzeptieren kann ja dieses agree to
disagree wie man so schön auch in
Jamaica immer sagt so ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt damit wir alle
Weiterkommen weil wir werden immer
verschieden sein so ja was ich auch
immer so schön sage als Beispiel
irgendwie du kannst nicht nach vatigan
City gehen und Kondomautomaten
aufstellen du kannst auch nicht in Iran
gehen und da die Leute fragen warum
tragt ihr hier alle Kopftücher und
genauso wenig kannst du sagen irgendwie
wie könnt ihr denn gegen Homosexualität
sein ich bin auch gegen diese krasse
Sprache die leider oft missverstanden
wird und trotzdem ist es eine Metapher
eine Symbolsprache aber ich find es gut
dass du mir die Frage stellst ist ein
Thema was im Moment sehr verbreitet ist
so es ist nur schade dass die ganze
positive Message die der regy ja auch
hat im Moment so ein bisschen aufgrund
dieses Themas auf der Strecke bleibt
lass dir gut gehen
ciao